هجوم ومطار السليمانيه الدولي فجر خلافا
جديدا ما بين الحزبين الكردستانيين
الرئيسيين الديمقراطي بزعامه مسعود
بارزاني والاتحاد الوطني بزعامه بافل
طالباني الاستهداف كان عبر طائره مسيره
تركيه بحسب المصادر لقائد قوات قصد مظلوم
عبدي المطلوب لتركيا البيانات الصحفيه
للاتحاد الوطني كانت غاضبه ومتهمه الشركه
ومديمقراطي كردستاني بانه متعاون مع تركيا
لاستهداف في مناطقه نفوذ الاتحاد الوطني
بحسب البيان طبعا الاتحاد الوطني سوف
يتاسف على هذا التصعيد الغير مبرر من
الحزب الديمقراطي واستهداف مناطق نفوذ
الاتحاد الوطني بشكل الوسائل بعضها
بالتعاون مع اطراف داخليه وبعضها بالتعاون
مع اطراف خارجيه وبالتحديد تركيا هذا
الاستهداف استهداف غير مبرر واخرها كان
استهداف مطار السليمانيه ونحن نقول لا
بنصح ان المطار سليماني من الطرف التركي
لكن كانت بدلائل داخليه وكان بتعاون داخلي
الموقف الاتحاد الوطني لكردستاني لم يذكر
تركيا في اتهاماته بشكل مباشر ولكنه
اتهمها ضمنا بالوقوف وراء الهجوم من جانبه
هاجم رئيس الجمهوريه عبد اللطيف رشيد
والمنتمي الى الاتحاد الوطني لكردستاني
هاجمت تركيا وطلبها بالاعتذار عن الهجوم
فيما طالب رئيسها اقليم كردستان لجربان
بارزاني الاطراف الكرديه بالتهدئه وضبط
النفس وافساح المجالي امام الجهات الامنيه
لاكمال التحقيق لا يمكن لاحد ان يتصور وان
يبين او يثبت تورط الحزب الديمقراطي بهذا
الموضوع ولكن بكل صراحه انا متاكد بان هذا
التوتر سوف يزال بعد عده ايام من خلال
الاجتماعات التي تعقد بين الجانبين وخصوصا
فيما يتعلق بمساله الانتخابات والانتخابات
سوف تحسن كل شيء